welcome to education I'm Kevin Smith and
I'm Andy McHale
oh my god man I've been dreaming about
this for awhile this I can't [ __ ]
wait to do this is the inaugural edition
of the edge of a pub quiz something an
Andy and I put together if you listen to
podcast education you heard us talk
about it on the last episode but the
idea was to put together a pub quiz
having never been to a pub quiz before
in my life so if you've been to pub
quizzes and you're like this is [ __ ]
this ain't right then that explains it
and [ __ ] but thankfully Andy's the smart
one and he's come up with five rounds of
really great [ __ ] questions five
questions at peace before we got here
hopefully you bought your cards each
round you'll have a chance at the end of
bye cards you need a card to play in the
round to qualify for the prizes they're
not prizes though right they are
exciting giveaways if the FCC is
listening they are have no monetary
value and so we've got excited giveaways
and [ __ ] like that the only thing you
need to do that to play is to have one
of those cards we've got five rounds the
first round will begin in a second but
we have to go through a list of rules
really it's not just to let you know
where we stand and what not so at the
end of the day nobody's like [ __ ] you
you [ __ ] said I'd win abroad see you
you may win over Otzi but like it's not
[ __ ] guaranteed you actually have to
be good at something and onenote
speaking of which holy [ __ ] this is
apropos of nothing but I want to see mr.
Roger what does it call won't you be my
neighbor the new documentary this
documentary out called won't you be my
neighbor it's a documentary about the
great mr. Rogers who hosted mr. Rogers
neighborhood for something like 30 plus
years right so I'm telling you it is not
enough to bring tissues to see it
because they're the tissues are
ineffective against the monster that
this movie is you need a beach towel for
the amount of crying that you [ __ ] do
it's funny to talk about crying yes I
wasn't talking about coming
it is incredibly [ __ ] powerful but as
he gets to the end of his life they talk
about he dealt with some like I didn't
realize this I didn't know this was
going on right before he died a couple
years before he died like Fox News did a
piece where they were like mr. Rogers
told an entire generation of kids
they're special and they're really not
did he [ __ ] up America what and I was
like [ __ ] heartbroken that this poor
guy who spent his whole life just
[ __ ] like working with kids he didn't
do it for the money he didn't do it for
the [ __ ] famous [ __ ] didn't do for
the I mean it was public broadcasting so
he certainly wasn't ambitious he just
believed that like kids needed to be
[ __ ] spoken to and toward the end of
his life somebody was like you [ __ ]
America Rogers like it was [ __ ]
heartbreaking that being said I forget
why I brought it I know he was like I
really wanted to get on a soapbox about
that for a minute I forget what it had
to do is I was thinking of the Venn
diagram it's comedy game fun bar
depressing story of rules I guess that
was my these are the rules for the pop
quiz but very simple we're gonna have
five rounds of five questions each team
you have teams hopefully pick names for
your teams I would think that's the
funnest part of this is coming up with a
[ __ ] team name yeah like that I would
have called mine wizard sleeve that
would be my team but I'm here up asking
a question so this I might you come up
with any name for your team five people
per team no more than five people per
team that's because of the prize
situation Andy take over well I you to
play around you need a round card you
can buy round cards for five dollars
each or for 24 set of five but only at
the beginning so if you want to play the
whole game you can get five for twenty
right now I think that did that border
it right we ask the questions you fill
in the answers on the cards right you're
clever team name at the bottom of the
card and make sure it's something that I
can pronounce and during gameplay you
can take pictures now you can shoot
video do whatever you want but wow the
questions are being asked to do for
worried are important is the most
important part of the
let's go cellphones down no use of the
Internet
yes you can if you're looking up the
[ __ ] answers on the internet like
this it all [ __ ] goes away and it's
right here this rule right here yes
cheaters are dicks and II wrote that
yeah more importantly where we're not
gonna like lock your [ __ ] phones in a
bag or anything like that but this and
it's not even the honor system I'm not
saying you're on your honor they're
[ __ ] cameras everywhere
and more importantly if you say is see
something say something if you see
somebody [ __ ] looking up the answer
be like ooh snitch we love that [ __ ]
that'll be great
so hopefully while the questions are
being asked phones down or in your
pocket between rounds while we're going
over the answers take your phones out
check your messages - [ __ ] like that but
we don't want to have to disqualify
people if we see you pull out a phone
after each round we collect the cards
and Big Daddy Jimmy B and Nagin's always
give it up for our helper monkey guys
these fine gentlemen are gonna scurry
like [ __ ] rats in that movie gonna
bend yes deep cuts pull they're gonna
grab your cards they're gonna go
tabulate all the cards to see who the
winner of the round is except while
they're doing that we're gonna be over
going over the answers with you guys and
stuff so hopefully shit'll be going out
at the same time so at the end of the
round if one of these two tunes starts
reaching for your card and [ __ ] don't be
like [ __ ] you that's their job so give
them the card you can have the card back
at the end of the night me and Andy
signed all of the [ __ ] game cards so
you can walk away with something at the
end of the night something worthless
like our autograph but it'll be there to
have if there's a tie at the end of the
round let's say like a couple teams get
the same exact score that's when we're
gonna take you to the Quadra gone ladies
a gentlemen one representative from each
team that's tied will come up here and
enter the Quadra gan-chan I wanted I was
gonna make an octagon but I I it was too
hard so I just made a four-sided quadric
on
but the quadric on is an evil mistress
and we will do roll-ups High Roller wins
and we here we have these cool 20 sided
dungeon in Dragonstone you'll be able to
play some dice and that'll decide any
kind of tied up round High Roller wins
at the end of the game team of the most
winning rounds is the winner there's a
game prize per each round that we'll go
through for the giveaway yes my bad not
a prize per each round
can we keep whoa is it possible to keep
it down just a little bit I know we're
in a bar and which is unreasonable for
me to ask for but just as we go over
through this [ __ ] that would go ahead
take over I got so end of the game the
team with the most winning rounds is the
winner
the winning team receives one edge of a
challenge coin so what is the challenge
coin Kevin shout you explain it a
challenge coin is basically it's a coin
that you can come in any of any time to
play any future game and you will get
five cards absolutely free so one team
will win one coin but they can all come
back to the team the next time and use
it
coins are not transferable but you will
and you can actually buy the coins next
time we haven't kind of figure that out
yet but right now we have a coin that is
a place or a coin that I made they are
wooden wooden coins but they are
actually like wooden nickels because the
new ones will be metal they're gonna be
nickel and you'll be able to use those
and come to any game and get all five
cards for free okay so that's at the end
of each round there's a prize winner of
that round takes that prize for you and
your team at the end of the whole night
we pick a winner of the entire night and
that's the person or the team that's won
the most amount of rounds that's where
the edge of my challenge coin comes into
play I think we've gone through
everything is that that's it alright
cheers it out of the way man let's talk
about round 1 what is round 1 round 1 is
the Terry Fox round okay so ladies and
gentlemen first round is a big out to
begin with the edge boom pop quiz first
round is the Terry Fox prep round we
made a movie called yoga hosers it was
the school that the girls went to was
called Terry Fox Prep in the scene at
the gym we had a bunch of kids dressed
in uniform for a school that didn't
exist
so it was all on camera wardrobe so I
have a [ __ ] tub of it and [ __ ] so the
winning team of this round gets five
screen-worn costumes from a movie that
nobody saw Yoko's you'll be able to walk
out of here dressed like a terry fox
prep [ __ ] if you can look at the size of
your costume and then watch the movie
and be like I think that's the costume
on that medium sized person absolutely
okay so five rounds it begins with that
first round everyone have your cards
ready does everyone have pens that's the
other thing I forgot did we give our
fans a chip Oh
are you [ __ ] me all right hey Jimmy
do you guys have extra pens back there
send someone who is store right now or
or just send someone to a store all
right as you can see we're building it
as it's progress
yeah [ __ ] like duh all right doesn't do
enough people have writing utensils does
every team have a writing utensil does
the team have extra writing utensils to
share with teams that don't until that
happens boy these guys are competitive
you know there's like 50 [ __ ] pen hey
Nate
he's got pens right there that's like
five pens he'll get like as many pens
like from a store right on the block
wherever right it's [ __ ] Hollywood
Boulevard it's right there okay all
right baby gotten to meanwhile let's
begin okay
what those what are they
pens who needs pens man throw your hands
up in the air over here whip one in that
corner just don't hit any button any
idea all right
enough pens out here we go settle down
folks settle down here we go quiet quiet
quiet we're beginning we're beginning
here we go bring it down yes here we go
first round of Ejim a pop quiz begins
ladies gentlemen Terry Fox round since
it was Terry Fox prep was a school all
of the questions of this round will be
High School
full movie TV show comic book themes so
that's what we're looking at the
questions are based in high school this
edition of the edge of a pop quiz all
the questions are based in one High
School in particular that high school is
ridgemont high these are questions have
to do with Fast Times at Ridgemont High
ladies and gentlemen put it together for
a movie we all love okay here we go
first question ready in Fast Times at
Ridgemont High what actor plays the
football player whose car gets wrecked
by Spicoli start writing ladies and
gentlemen don't say it out loud I know
you want to but don't you might give
away the answer in Fast Times at
Ridgemont High what actor plays the
football player whose car gets wrecked
by Jeff Spicoli famous actor very famous
actor I'm writing I'm taking the time in
my head to write it I know I'm a slow
writer I'm done so slowly the same for a
turn okay question number one one last
time in fast times what actor plays the
football player whose car gets wrecked
by Jeff Spicoli hold on to that thought
people on ludes should not drive nice
number two question Phoebe Cates from
Fast Times at Ridgemont High has been
married nearly 30 years to what famous
actor who was not in Fast Times at
Ridgemont High correct there you go
ladies and gentlemen answered that
Phoebe Cates the amazing Phoebe Cates
comes out of the pool amongst other
things she's the one that played Linda
in Fast Times absolutely right Linda
Phoebe Cates has been married nearly 30
years to what famous actor this famous
actor was not in Fast Times at Ridgemont
High that's correct
Linda means beautiful in Latin did you
know that I did not yes where'd you get
that from well that's what it means as
the guy who writes the questions you
could think about that maybe I good well
done a little bit of trivia there
according to Andy okay
one more time with the question ladies
and gentlemen Phoebe Cates has been
married nearly 30 years to what famous
actor and this actor was not in Fast
Times at Ridgemont High write that [ __ ]
down because we're about to go to
question number three in Fast Times at
Ridgemont High
what does Spicoli do to disrupt mr.
hands class very classic scene everybody
remembers at least from our generation
in Fast Times Ridgemont High
what is Jeff Spicoli do to disrupt mr.
hands class Andy has quiz master how did
you come up with the questions I sat
down and thought of them and then I
typed them amazing man what do you think
the chances are you're a math guy what
are the chances that we will have two
people will have to enter the code quad
dragon quadric on it does say they have
the word dragon in it which makes it
even more bad i [ __ ] [ __ ] it up
thank you what are the chances we go
into the quadriga I think the chances
are one in three that we will not have a
quadric on off and then every round is
that based on math it's based on the the
how hard the questions are that's really
how you write these whole things you
know I've worked on some game shows in
my life and it's really the ebb and flow
of a game is how to make them hard and
easy so right now the what disrupts mr.
hands class probably easy for a lot of
these areas a question boy this could
change in the very next question
they [ __ ] better but here's my
question if you're gonna say that you
worked on game shows if you're gonna
talk about how big your dick is whip it
out what game shows have your work done
well first of all it is not about my
dick and second I just worked on the
Joker's wild with Snoop really yes
so you're legit worked on a game I
exclusively work with people that smoked
a lot of marijuana while they work one
last time with that question ladies and
gentlemen in Fast Times at Ridgemont
High
what does Jeff Spicoli do to disrupt mr.
hands class Andy you get over the last
two questions all right yeah we are in
depends anyone need a pen this one says
Hollywood on it
give it up for Nate easy they say they
donate pens if you need them right here
ladies and gentlemen Fast Times at
Ridgemont High is one of those fun to
end titles where they tell you what
happens to the characters next in the
end titles of Fast Times who does
Spicoli saved from drowning only to blow
the money on getting Van Halen
to play his birthday party whoo so
that's what happens then he saves a
famous person from drowning but he just
goes on and blows the money to get van
Halen to play his birthday pledge it I
don't even remember I'm not asking for
help I'm just saying like I don't even
remember right now that's well you don't
win the t-shirts my friend I know it's
big tough times and again here we go in
the end titles of fast times who does
Spicoli save from drowning only to blow
the money on getting Van Halen to play
his birthday party Spicoli saved someone
from drowning famous person write it
down we did our where are they now end
titles for Mallrats based on the ones
from past times same font I believe in
it was that was my request so is that
kind of look exactly like a very
successful movie and it did not know it
but I stole that idea from them in the
end titles one more time ladies
gentlemen write down write your answers
down we're almost at the end of the
round
in the end titles of Fast Times Romano
who does piccoli save from drowning only
to blow the money on getting van Halen
to play his birthday party is a
celebrity of some sort it is a very
famous celebrity and there it is magic
fourth question the final question of
this round ladies gentlemen round one of
the edge of a pop quiz Terry Fox round
coming to a close and the final question
as written by Education Andy himself
professor education and I'm not a real
professor is is what is the very last
spoken line of Fast Times at Ridgemont
High Oh last line what is the last
spoken line of Fast Times at Ridgemont
High if you read the script there's a
punctuation mark then this line and then
it's the end of the movie
write that down add that into your final
slot ladies and gentlemen and the boys
Big Daddy Jimmy V and Nate are gonna be
ready to accept your cards all you need
to do is put your hand in the air and
the boys are gonna collect your cards
man car all right car big sister out now
you guys got it everybody got their
cards ready now I see game let's hear
some of their common dirt say it again
it went from really easy for the first
three questions they're like [ __ ] you
hard to lost ooh that's a [ __ ] that is a
challenge Andy McHale firs approach man
just the tip and then all the way we did
it he'll impress you with his thick and
fat very Nate we got some over here card
collection ladies and gentlemen I'm
going your cards for real locking down
the clocks round all right no not that
upfront Jimmy right here at the bar
anybody else
everybody in mister complainy at the bar
is not finished you know look at those
shirts look at these [ __ ] five sets
it's a t-shirt and a [ __ ] set of
shorts who has the Terry Fox logo on it
yeah was seen in a movie yes nobody saw
the movie so this tree fell in the woods
and nobody [ __ ] heard it and stuff
but you've got a whole team right here
it goes extra-large how many what were
that what was the double size it went
from an extra large to extra larges yes
there are two extra larges and then a
small medium and large yes so if you've
got an appropriately sized family and/or
[ __ ] volleyball team you're all good
man five outfits we've got cards being
collected have we gotten them all all
the cards are in your hands ladies and
gentlemen throw your hands up if you
haven't turned your card in yet no cards
are out all right the tabulation pixies
hard when we apply the card right here
night Nate right there any last cards
because we're about to give you the
answers folks any last cards get an
ending in five
for well done three everyone got their
card in to one okay that's the end of
the round ladies you can put your hands
together man Terry Fox round is over we
did it round one
[Applause]
okay let's get to the bottom of these
very tough questions man and he's got
the car answer key while the boys are
tabulating this rounds winner we'll go
over the answers number one in fast
times what actor plays the football
player whose car gets wrecked by Jeff
Spicoli Andy what is the answer to that
why it's the Last King of Scotland
Scotland himself Forest Whitaker Forest
Whitaker Lear olives the second film he
sees the one that growls don't [ __ ] with
it yeah Horace [ __ ] winter girl also
makes that the lion sound when he's in
his helmet you can't fix that car unless
your dad's a refrigerator repairman with
great tools number two the question was
Phoebe Cates has been married nearly
thirty years to what famous actor who
was not in Fast Times at Ridgemont hi
Andy why it's Kevin Kline Kevin Kline
that's right she was originally cast as
the young girl in The Big Chill but they
decided not to keep her role and that's
where they met and they stayed on
together and so while they didn't star
in that movie together they met there a
stalker of Phoebe Cates guys more of a
Kevin Kline stalker okay number three in
Fast Times Ridgemont High
what does Jeff Spicoli do to disrupt mr.
hands class I think every answer this
one he orders a pizza I heard somebody
say masturbate no clearly they didn't
see the movie that's right he orders a
pizza that seemed to be the easiest
question in the round you never saw that
movie mr. head you dick yes
number four man in the end titles of
Fast Times at Ridgemont High who does
Jeff Spicoli saved from drowning only to
blow the money on getting van Halen to
play his birthday party who knows it
hand up Brooke Shields yeah yes give it
up for ladies jump that was [ __ ] hard
I did
no I know just like in real life Brooke
Shields stands alone yes well [ __ ]
done man that was tough - how many
people did not get Brooke Shields throw
your hands up
yeah I'm in that majority as well okay
and the last question in the round was
what was the last line of Fast Times
Ridgemont higher this to me felt like a
trick question because you could say
what is the last line but you said the
last spoken set of words that would be
the last sentence so if I had to guess
it's not awesome totally awesome way to
go Hamilton way to go Hamilton yes got
it
way to go Hamilton tough one the trailer
moment is awesome totally awesome but
there's one more line Hamilton foils the
robbery at the 7-eleven yes [ __ ] when I
was writing clerks one of the reasons I
wrote clerks was because I was like
nobody's ever made a whole movie in a
convenience store like yes Fast Times
ends at a convenience store but what
have you just stayed there for a whole
[ __ ] flick so Fast Times means a lot
to me men all right there it is the end
of the Terry Fox round we know what the
answers are we're waiting to find out
who won that round and if those winners
have to face each other in the Quadra
grande so we got some [ __ ] time to
kill so what we did was bring some
[ __ ] swag man and since JC
is letting us do this show right here at
the scum and villainy canteen on
Hollywood Boulevard put your hands
together so the folks are really real we
got to try to make them some loot so
what we're gonna do is do a mini game
within the game I've worked on a bunch
of [ __ ] TV shows and so we wind up
making shirts for those TV shows so here
is a TV show that I made for the folks
who worked on one of the last episodes
of Supergirl that I directed it's got a
storyboard on it
and when I direct I'm barely a director
you ask any critic they'll [ __ ] tell
you when I direct what I do is I make
people applaud at the end of the take so
once it take is down I was a godly chef
that was amazing put your hands together
just like I forced you people to applaud
here same thing on a set I'm always like
put your hands together so they always
say like you bring the clap when you
come so the shirt says I caught a case
of the clap from Kevin Smith on episode
217 Supergirl okay this shirt is sized
extra-large is the only one that I got
here at the house and certainly the only
one I got here at the bar what we're
gonna do is this man first will say who
wants to play for it and so we'll see
how many hands go up and [ __ ] first ones
I see you're gonna play for it and stuff
what you have to do is buy a round of
[ __ ] knockers and answer a question [ __ ]
knockers is a non-alcoholic drink so I'm
not making you drink I don't want to be
[ __ ] me - this is a non-alcoholic
drink virgin drink no boozing and [ __ ]
like that and you could buy for your
table you could buy for anybody else so
have the option of booze of hanging it
if you wish you can put booze in it if
you want and stuff that's up to you okay
who wants to play for the shirt hands in
the air BAM I saw that hand go right up
first I bless all this cap first so that
would be weird um all right who's got a
microphone Jason you got a Roman Mike or
anything here it is
middle guy red shirt right there what's
your name man into the mic
he can't let's leave him there because
he's [ __ ] trapped and Josh josh
everyone give it up for Josh man
all right so Josh there's one of two
ways to win this year you answer a
question or you buy a [ __ ] round of
[ __ ] knockers you okay with this yeah
man I think we can talk you into
anything okay
here we go for the shirt come up a bit
let's see let's come up a question ah
thank you you you got a question in your
head no you were asked questions about
this very show that you were giving it
was that uh or we can make you do [ __ ]
do you know are you a singer
oh no that's not perfect but but if we
gave you the words would you sing for us
I don't think I could do it man I'm
sorry well think about nobody could see
you're tucked away in the back of the
booth mm-hmm and what I'll do is I'll
have JC hold the shirt in front of your
face so nobody could [ __ ] see you
yeah pocket for drinks okay we got to
give let me see do you know this hold on
not yet I gotta see his face first look
me in the eye
do you know the theme song to the
spider-man cartoon spider-man yeah yeah
yeah the whole song
da does whatever is fun
if you sing the whole song correctly you
win that [ __ ] shirt nothing if you get
one [ __ ] word wrong like if you say
Wahb instead of web [ __ ] you then you
got to buy a round of [ __ ] knockers
agreed yes okay put the shirt in front
of his face he's about to sing lazy imma
give it up for a man who's a recovery
[Applause]
on the count of three one two you got a
build up to it do you have some honey
first or [ __ ] this alright here we go
you ready you feeling it this is you
conquering every [ __ ] fear you've
ever had in life if you can do this what
can't you [ __ ] do man think about it
like that you ready to sing all right
let's do this here we go count three one
two three go spider-man spider-man does
whatever a spider can but it was so
[ __ ] close give it up for a meet just
bought a router [ __ ] guys everyone a
shirt give that [ __ ] shirt a shirt
that was make him wear it
that was okay the only way you could
have made that worse as if his entire
second grade class was here and he was
naked that's true we could have made him
take off his pants excellent job all
right we got a results of the many teams
here only two teams managed to score
four out of five and so they're gonna
face each other off in the quadriga
ladies and gentlemen whoa those teams
are dogmatic where do we have dogmatic
talk okay ended up over here solo team
solo team solo send one representative
up here come up yeah that to the quadric
I feel like he might be by himself in
team solo you're so low I'm so low but
Mike JC you got a mic Oh take that bad
boy give auntie back is Mike alright so
we have a who's who do we have here
let's find out what's your name sir no
Matt everyone give it up for Matt team
solo
and team dogmatic what's your name
surname Ryan Ryan everyone give it up
for Ryan man so the idea here is each of
you takes your own dice and one by one
throws it into the quadric on and the
high-roller wins get it high roller all
right here we go man and just watch
ground one one die of peace
all right team solo is the winner
well done team solo take your booty five
shirts for one guy that was adorable
he's like it was like that moment went
[ __ ] Ving Rhames gave away his Golden
Globe to Jack Lemmon and [ __ ] that was
sweet yeah all right here we go folks
the Terry Fox round is done we got our
winner and now we're about to enter
round two the brats around put your
hands together ladies and gentlemen the
brats around we did for the brats around
you will be winning a actual screen-used
brats from the movie yoga hosers man
this was on a set standing in for
whatever Leigh Andy would turn into a
digital version that was the only used
to stand on the shelf while you made
pelvic thrusting motion as you're at
your daughter that's right and you could
own this [ __ ] brats see if you win
this round man the questions
Bharati is handmade by famous special
effects artist Bob Kurtzman he's
absolutely painted Robert Kurtzman who
made Marky Mark's dick in Boogie Nights
made that which was actually longer than
a proxy you're not kidding man okay
Brock see round questions or monster
questions every question has to do with
a monster ladies and gentlemen do you
have your cards ready
everyone [ __ ] you do you have your cards
ready very nice everybody have a pen
this time around yes there you go
everyone good fantastic here we go the
round begins ladies and gentlemen it's
round two the bronze around and the
first question comes from the lips of
Professor Andrew McHale fresh go
what is the Japanese name of Godzilla I
see a lot of smiling people in the
audience that's right you heard the man
what is the Japanese name of Godzilla
Godzilla movie coming what's that
Godzilla movie chemistry picture and
Entertainment Weekly of total using his
atomic breath Godzilla king of the wild
frontier if I'm not wrong I think so he
wore a raccoon hat didn't he born on a
mountaintop and Buster Island once
fought Mothra and King Kong twice one
more time with that question ladies and
gentleman first question in round 2 what
is the Japanese name for Godzilla
[ __ ] is it here we go moving on to
question number 2 ready what actress
plays Charlize Theron
love interest in the 2003 serial killer
biopic monster counts as a monster
question ladies and gentlemen what
actress plays Charlize Theron love
interest in the 2003 serial killer
biopic monster so drink your monster
energy drink it as we prepare for that
where'd you pull that question for it
from just out of my brain it always
surprised me when I thought of it oh I
thought this was a good question tricky
Dicky man I just want to point out for
the record Andy of course made not just
the question cards that I'm holding but
also the score cards that y'all are
writing on he designed it himself and
then laser printed them and cut them
himself in his [ __ ] little lab man
give it that free Oh No please please
thank you so much oh he's his own little
[ __ ] staples I made
that quadriga - it's a box okay last
time what is the Japanese name for
Godzilla that was question number one
question no I mean I was - [ __ ] I forgot
we're on number two what actress plays
Charlize Theron love interest in the
2003 serial killer biopic monster now
we're moving on to question three ladies
and gentlemen question three in Game of
Thrones a warg is a person that communes
with animals but in Lord of the Rings a
warg is a monster what kind of monster
is it I see some people dancing in their
chairs over here I think they know their
rings fans yeah in Game of Thrones a
warg as a person that communes with
animals like [ __ ] beretta bran right
yeah talks to birds and [ __ ] yeah
Brando he goes right through you he goes
right into a bird but in Lord of the
Rings a warg is a monster what kind of
monster is it I don't know enough about
these Rings movies except that there's a
lot of walking well you know there's a
lot of talk about how much
HRR Martin took from junior art Okun
including both of his middle initials
and a little sprinkle of HR Pufnstuf as
well there's a dragon he was some of
there's a lot of similar words but in
this case they mean something different
they absolutely do when grouped together
it's a magic spell last time for that
question in Game of Thrones a warg as a
person that communes with animals but in
Lords a warg is a monster what kind of
monster is it what was that little Irish
accident at the end I threw it in there
butcher I was speaking Madonna British I
just went up at the end all right we're
moving on to question number four ladies
gentlemen and Andy Mikkel first has that
question for you take it away Andy okay
everybody ready spell Cthulhu there it
is ladies and gentlemen spell kuku Lulu
we're Cthulhu created by HP Lovecraft
meant to represent one all the evil and
[ __ ] yeah lots of evil
it shows up for evil spell Cthulhu write
it down you spell it right you win that
question that's correct spelling
and we're Len Turing into the last
question of the brats around ladies and
gentlemen last question of the brats
around here we go
tell him Andy are you saying that
somewhat the team that wins the most of
these questions wins that brats eat
that's right very exciting whatever wins
this round is gonna win this screen-used
broth seed you're gonna have to explain
this to people that never saw the movie
what is that and then you'll be like
well it's a long story I'll tell the pop
quiz and I want it I never saw the movie
all right last question everybody ready
in which version of the Godzilla movies
that have been on screen so far is
Godzilla the tallest in which version of
the Godzilla movies that have been made
is Godzilla the tallest which Godzilla
movie features the tallest Godzilla thus
far you can name the year you can name
the director just identify the movie
which one now there were a bunch of
Godzilla movies man so be careful
there's Godzilla versus Mothra which is
obviously not the answer otherwise he
never would have given it to can you
what yes we verified question being
asked from the audience was your name
give it up or so susan has a question or
a separate entities what a great
question the question is do does
Mechagodzilla or other incarnations of
Godzilla count in this particular line
yes judge is the edge of a writer of the
question right this is no no
Mechagodzilla is not Godzilla I don't
wanna get in a fight over this but I got
to tell you it's just Godzilla in any
movie that he was so mecha godzilla is a
separate character in this question
we're eliminating mecha godzilla cuz
he's a robot version that's hence the
mecha i was life honestly what a great
question and give me that [ __ ] mecha
question it was legit
don't don't gas lighter because you
didn't like the question and don't be
confused cuz Mechagodzilla where he goes
on the religious quest to Mecca that's a
totally different movie
Mechagodzilla last time folks in which
version of the Godzilla movies is
Godzilla the tallest when you have
finished off you're right right in to
the end of the round ladies and
gentlemen throw your hands in the air
alright wave them like you just don't
care Nate and her daddy Jimmy B you're
gonna take them away from you and we can
tell you what the answers are good here
you go Nate Nate right here at the bar
thank you sir somebody's gonna walk away
with a bra see that's true hey some team
and if you've got a lot of people on
your team you got to figure out who
shares the bra see who gets the bronzy
you could give it away a week at a time
you could be like I don't want that and
opt out of it altogether you could
travel with it like a little garden
gnome yes you could pass it around and
[ __ ] like that it could be a Christmas
thing oh yeah [ __ ] yeah watch this
throw your hands up folks if you
finished filling out your card all cards
are in here maybe we got one more card
out here time is up we got to tabulate
those scores everybody in everybody in
on this side excellent very good anyone
still have a card in their hands anyone
still filling out their cards need any
more time everyone covered cards up
ladies and gentlemen now if you've been
getting in fights with your teammates
you can always split off on your own
team and buy new cards and start your
own that's absolutely true man and we
got another round coming up so if you
wanna buy some more round cards need
some more cards man I think they're
being sold over there yeah okay man
where everyone's cards in cards in all
right hosing this round in five seconds
five four three two one perfect this is
the end of the round put your hands
together ladies and gentlemen it we
accomplished something okay let's go
through the answers professor Andrew
Mikkel fish number one not a real
professor
what is the Japanese name for Godzilla
Andy Gojira Gojira that's right Oh G
right now there's a little story behind
that a lot of people think because they
think it's a Kumasi of the Japanese word
for bear and the Japanese word for whale
but according to the director of the
first film it was actually the nickname
of a huge grip on set that everybody
called Gojira and that's where they got
the name
we should named after a fat guy on say
number two what actress plays Charlize
Theron love interest in the 2003 serial
killer biopic a monster it's Wednesday
Addams herself christina ricci Hristina
Ricci later
the answer we were reaching for
christina ricci number three in game of
thrones a warg as a person that communes
with animals and E but in Lord of the
Rings a warg as a monster
what kind of monster is it it is a giant
wolf
it's what the orcs ride into battle is
the giant wolf we got a lot of giant
well fancier or ladies and gentlemen I
would like a there's everything I would
have easily lost that round I didn't
know that at all okay here we go number
four the question for number four was
spell Cthulhu so take it away Andy
battle Cthulhu and here we go it's C
hold on let's do it all together count
three ladies gentlemen one two three C T
H u L H you Oh somebody just had a no
[ __ ] moment right there yeah and second
to their booth god I forgot that [ __ ]
age I would not have gotten that second
age that's that that [ __ ] silent H
I'll kill you every time okay and the
final question of the round was in which
version of the Godzilla movies is
Godzilla the tallest and E which movie
wasn't it is the very latest theatrical
release in 2014 ladies and gentlemen
along with Elizabeth Olsen a limit the
elizabeth Olsen God Miller Walter White
isn't it yes and he stands a massive 350
feet high in the original film he was
only 100 feet high but in this film
because the model makers couldn't make
the models smaller right look realistic
that's so that's why he was a hundred
now they just used CGI and in the very
next movie Godzilla king of the monsters
that's the one that's coming out he will
be even taller they're estimating he
could be as tall as four hundred feet
what what did they give a reason why he
got bigger I don't know like it's a
growth spurt yeah
alright that's all your monster
questions ladies and gentlemen and we're
waiting of course for our cards to be
tabulated by Big Daddy Jimmy V and Biden
eight so while we're doing that hey
let's play another [ __ ]
ladies and gentlemen all right over
there
directed another episode of Supergirl
wait for him to ask and I made this
shirt to go around It's Made carrying
Supergirl Supergirl carrying me rather
when I wore this on set everybody was
like oh you're a big fan of Hillary
Clinton I see they all thought this
rendering was by a Hillary Clinton it's
not it's meant to be Melissa of course
this was drawn by the the storyboard
artists of Supergirl and flash mr.
jeremy simpson he also works on Game of
Thrones as well this is a shirt I gave
out for not the last but maybe the last
episode or no the episode I did before
that and stuff so same thing man round a
[ __ ] knockers or you got to answer a
question who wants to play for the shirt
hand went up right there I just saw okay
get him a microphone
JC start thinking of a question oh gosh
put them in the spot in the spot right
here about a wall what's your name young
camper Nate everyone give it up for Nate
man is your microphone on I can't yes
yes all right there we go
okay man so you've seen the booty and
[ __ ] you know the rules you either go
answer a question correctly and win this
and if you answered incorrectly you got
to be around a bio round of virgin [ __ ]
knockers agreed yeah done and done okay
question I'm still thinking for our Lady
we can make them do [ __ ] like not not
like take your [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like I'm not doing gym don't don't
bow to the crowd pressure man but but
maybe we should call it like truth or
dare right so it's like the round is
truth or dare so truth is you answer
question or dare as you [ __ ] it do some
[ __ ] but you got a question well we
could keep with it's christina ricci and
you have to name five christina ricci
movies
done and done can you name in 30 seconds
5 christina ricci movies ready to do
that
ok start time and you count it count out
loud ready and quietly Gemma this
requires concentration he's naming
christina ricci move it's god this is
her t-shirt ladies and gentlemen here we
go and go Adams family ghost world
monster you just have to say 5 keep
going so far you've got to Adams oh yeah
Casper that's 3 10 9 8 7 6
- what was lilac Snake Moan Black Snake
Moan not those four not five you lost
give it up for ladies and gentlemen just
bought some [ __ ] virgins excellent
[ __ ] job well done we'll take that
mic up signal okay man looks like we got
our cards back and I think we're ready
to find out what happened in that round
we got him we got him we got more than
one winner we got two winners they're
gonna have to face each other down in
the quad rag on here we go ladies and
gentlemen out to find out the winner of
round 2 the brats around take it away
Andy well we have death blossom your
representatives one representative from
death blossom please end and we have
again solo solo one again back solo you
Pub Quiz [ __ ] okay man where
there was a microphone that went away
but so you got all lean across to you
what's your name captain Eric Eric
everyone give it up for Eric man and
solo is back and solos back was your
name again
man Matt's back give it up for Matt
ladies gentlemen they are about to enter
the quadric on one roll at a time how
about you will will make a dramatic
right well [ __ ] it hold it up for the
camera they can't see it yeah we need an
overhead camera in the future bang one
at a time hold on what do we got
nineteen that's gonna be tough to beat
119 very wet soggy give it up for a
[ __ ]
all right team death blossom team death
blossom well done
what a sore winner he like [ __ ] you
while I was exciting man an excellent
job [ __ ] Matt seems to be the guy to
[ __ ] beat man oh that's got a little
actually going we're it not for the role
of a die you could have had it okay here
we go round three is about to begin
ladies gentlemen anybody need a blank
card does anybody need a blank card all
good in the hood here we go round three
is entitled the raw round ladies and
gentlemen that's because all the prizes
right here are from the good folks at
raw the people what you can win right
here is a fantastic rollin tray a bunch
of papers and a little rolling kit so if
you're like I don't know how to roll
joints they're gonna [ __ ] do it for
you man and that is hand put together
and styled by mr. Kevin Smith himself I
did I put that little basket together
okay so for the raw round and they're
not a sponsor I just have a lot of raw
product for the raw round we have put
together or I should say Andy has put
together weed related questions this
round is all about weed related
questions man so the insight dope if you
will that's right man
there's a high chance you'll get
questions right if you know anything
about weed in this round here we go
ladies gem the raw round is about to
begin question number one is CBD as in
CBD oil is an abbreviation for what
hahaha my man goes [ __ ] yes that is not
the key D as in CBD oil CBD is an
abbreviation for what start writing that
[ __ ] down lay down this is something
that I have a 70% chance of getting
right I might spell it wrong it does
spelling count you know what pop quiz
unless I'm in on Cthulhu yes but on solo
it does but no if you get close to the
answer our gentle giants that are answer
that are correct in the cards they will
give it to you you just have to be close
one last time ladies gentlemen question
1 round 3 CBD is an abbreviation for
what what does CBD mean and if you don't
know don't write something dirty we have
very sensitive graders number 2 this is
[ __ ] tough this is gonna take a few
seconds put together in your head so I'm
gonna give you some time to think about
it ready ladies Joe and the question
number two in round three is how many
states in the United States of America
have made it legal to smoke marijuana
without a prescription if you are 21 or
older looking for this names eight of
the states that have legalized marijuana
no no just the number just the number
that's the number how I didn't read that
correctly at all Wow mine was much
tougher than this you don't just write
all the states and you're right my bad
if my states in the USA have made it
legal to smoke marijuana without a
prescription if you were 21 or older you
just have to provide the number the
number of states the active ingredient
is States oh that sounds like a hint
right there how many states in the USA
there are 50 to choose from have made it
legal to smoke weed without a
prescription as long as you're 21 or
older altered states do not count
why did you include the 21 or older just
because that's the actual law is that it
yeah because you can buy marijuana in
many other states with the prescription
and but you still have to be 21 or older
to smoke it legally in any of those
states so I just put it in just so
people knew it's mine I like that that's
how we learned [ __ ] here on education ok
one last time what ladies gentleman how
many states in the USA have made it
legal to smoke marijuana without a
prescription if you're 21 or older
looking for a number write that number
down because we're about to go to
question number 3 in round 3 is in 2014
the DEA released a report on the
strength of new marijuana strains on
average how much stronger is 2014 weed
compared to the weed of 1995 looking for
a number here one time stronger two
times stronger three times stronger 4x5
way up to whatever number you want to
include how many times stronger very
famous reports covered on all the
national news warning to parents that
weed is stronger now than it has ever
been but by how much I wonder could be
one time two times three times four to
make five times six times could be a
thousand times may you live to be a
thousand years old it could be ten
thousand take a shot in 2014 ladies and
gentlemen
somebody will grab it we got somebody
here wants a drink I think over there no
worries no worries high in 2014 that's
what we were about that's like what your
money one more time of that question in
2014 the DEA released a report on the
strength of new marijuana strains on
average how much stronger is 2014 weed
compared to 1995 weed give me a number
throw a number down ladies and gentlemen
because we're about to move to the next
question or just take a stab if you
don't know that's true leaving it blank
educated guess here we go round three
question four
the fourth question ladies gentlemen the
penultimate question of this round is
what popular prescription drug does
marijuana keep from breaking down with
an embarrassing side effect that's right
there is a popular prescription drug
that you see advertised on the news
every night
maybe not last night that if you smoke
marijuana and have a high concentration
in your bloodstream it does not break
down and the side of
can be embarrassing even if you don't
know your pharmaceuticals and never
watch late-night television I bet you
could take a stab in the dark yes what
popular prescription drug does marijuana
keep from breaking down with an
embarrassing side effect looking for the
name of a prescription drug ladies and
gentlemen a prescription drug that and
we got one more question ago we do close
out this round one more question and
this is for the deep dive in junior or
rallying JK Rowling fan number 5 is
gonna be a tough one ladies and
gentlemen but don't worry about it
because somebody's gonna win could be
you I'll get guarantee you know but this
is the round that probably has the least
amount of accurate answer I think you
might be right I'm a smoker and I didn't
know any of this [ __ ] so if you were
sitting there going what an unfair round
give it up for Professor Andrew McAfee
it's fair if everyone gets the same
question it's true and you might even
learn something here we go that's true
imagine you might walk away learning
something ladies and gentlemen last time
what popular prescription drug does
marijuana keep from breaking down with
an embarrassing side effect heavily
heavily advertised drug many jokes made
about this drug here we go folks we're
heading into the last question the final
question of round 3 ready for this
professor Andrew Mikkel first take it
away we all know that mughals mughals
from the harry potter books are non
magical people and but in the 1926
wisecrack dictionary what our muggles
defined as and there's a rumor that this
is where JK Rowling actually got the
word route mughals mughals what does it
mean are y'all are muggles in the Harry
Potter world just to give a little
background the 1926 wisecrack dictionary
was like the urban slang dictionary of
its time police departments around the
country would gather criminal element
slang for drugs and they put it all into
this little dictionary and muggles
refers to something specific sir
muggles ladies and gentlemen last time
with the question muggles and Harry
Potter
non-magic people but in 1926 wisecrack
dictionary what our Mughals defined as
all you have to do is write down a word
ladies and gentlemen a word right
probably has something to do with the
subject matter of the round that would
be marijuana this is the wheat round
this is the weed round let's narrow it
down for you the raw round okay
everybody who's got their cards alright
if you're done answering those questions
throw your hand in the air if you want
your card taken Nate and Big Daddy Jimmy
beer sitting there running around doing
that very thing picking up your cards
once the cards are collected we will
give you the answers this I think for my
money was the toughest round very hard
we want to make that marijuana around a
difficult to achieve I know that should
probably be the easiest one but yeah
it's like what is this spell cat
anyone else ladies gentlemen anyone have
a car going to get their cards in and
turn in your card and we'll start giving
you answers ladies gentlemen cards cards
every cards of the card right there down
here we have a card card right there man
whose hand went up got it
cards cards everywhere cards cards cards
cards I had a you got a sharpie I know
man get all Michonne boss all those
cards collected take over boss take over
take over Andy Oh
so yes we're thinking about marijuana
questions coming up next we will have
the education round education round
where you all be vying for up to five
education books yes it's the education
book the informative witty and
incredibly written book by yours truly
that gives you fun facts and details
that were first gleaned in our podcast
and are now available for sale at at
stores like the Natural History Museum
ah look there's an education book right
there you can hold it up for us later
gentlemen Sean bus are
our extra vacation fine and feathered
fan Shawn buzz you traveled from where
to get here tonight
Columbus [ __ ] Ohio ladies and
gentlemen yes you're an edge of a pop
quiz it up man and he is not won a
single round okay all cards have been
collected all cards aren't yeah it's
officially closed us applaud ourselves
for finishing round three this was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] of a round man you came up
with some pretty hardcore questions
let's see who let's see man that's
awesome is that a homemade ROTC your
twelve-year-old daughter made this look
at this his twelve-year-old daughter
made of ROTC head that's adorable
what is her name is this the note a
letter from her can I read it
his 12 year old kid wrote me a letter
ladies and gentlemen so we have to look
at this real quick
dear mr. Kevin Smith well mister my name
is Wendy Elizabeth 30:13 yeah explain
that she's a number like she liked that
[ __ ] TV show like 11 or something you
picked a number for her middle name yeah
that's so awesome so instead of like
bill or seryeong [ __ ] it 13 yeah pretty
much
yeah that's awesome so combination
misprint something she's like Reimers is
the last name yeah and it's numerical
it's not spelled out yes it's number 13
yeah Wendy Elizabeth 13 Reimers I'm 12
years old I have seen your movie yoga
hosers and I liked it a lot oh man
did she pay Netflix Netflix I guess it
was goofy but I liked it everyone's a
[ __ ] critic the first time I watch it
was so funny the second time it was
still funny oh I could put that on a
poster maybe tell her thank you this
movie never gets old in a weird way you
got my dad and I to bond over that movie
because now we can bother my mom oh
that's cute so you guys could like do
proxy [ __ ] or I was running around
yelling like moon dubrow and pretty much
most the time like yeah that's awesome
man I did the same thing to my wife I'm
like Munda Bosch she's like shut the
[ __ ] up I made a broth see out of clay
but it has not been fired yet so we have
to be careful but can you please sign it
and sorry a boot asking that was
adorable a boot
sorry boot asking but if you make
another movie and you need a
twelve-year-old I will be there that's
fantastic I am a shorty 1 I am a shorty
so I can do what 6 to 12 I could be
younger if you want a movie oh she could
play it down as you say yeah she's like
I got range [ __ ] like [ __ ] Meryl
Streep I got range love when DPS thank
you for reading this also I'm in an
advanced drama so I can act holy [ __ ]
well done oh my god nobody has asked me
this in [ __ ] years the letter ends
with her saying want to be pen pals and
then she gave me an address and like
nobody does anymore because most people
who like just test but I would love to
be a pen pal I'm actually gonna start
pen back that's [ __ ] dope and then
back to her there all right I'm gonna
side tag that you take it
yeah I keep this I know I just admitted
on [ __ ] video that I'm gonna become
to befriend a 12 year old girl but I
don't think that's weird
at least there's evidence that it seemed
like a saint but as a parent to another
parent you should monitor that
relationship okay here we go
the pub quiz round 3 was all about we
draw round Andy's got the answers I
still got to tag it the question first
one was CBD as in CBD oil Andy what is
that an abbreviation for Kennedy all
cannabadiol lissu cannabidiol it sounds
like a southern person asking to join an
auction can i biddy all can i biddy all
cannabinol canapa to command a video is
that how you say it
yeah okay that was a [ __ ] tough one
anybody get that correct is anyone
taking CBD oil has anyone ever read the
label on it that was a tough one man
alright number two how many states in
the USA have made it legal to smoke
marijuana without a prescription if you
were 21 or older looking for a number in
the number 8 answer is 9 there are nine
states nine states plus the District of
Columbia which we did give you as a clue
is not one of the 50 states so the
number we were looking for was 9 those
states are Alaska Alaska California
Colorado Maine Massachusetts Nevada
Oregon Vermont and Washington state nice
and Washington DC okay number three was
in 2014 the DEA released a report on the
strength of new marijuana strains on
average how much stronger is 2014 weed
compared to 1995 weed we asked you to
put in a number here we go three times
it is three times stronger we got some
winners over here three times stronger
once twice three times as potent number
four what popular prescription drug does
marrow
to keep from breaking down with an
embarrassing side effect on the count of
three the whole audience one two three
viagra absolutely if you defy Agra than
you have not paid attention to TV for
the last 10 [ __ ] years
viagra number five an erection lasting
more than four hours you may be high
number five was tough I think muggles
and Harry Potter are non magic people
but in the 1926 wisecrack dictionary
Andy what are muggles defined as joints
they are marijuana cigarettes mughals
mughals speaking of windy we got some
winners over here and it comes from
smuggling them behind your ear oh you
put it beyond yours you're like a muggle
in it you're smuggling me
speaking of muggles ladies gentlemen
when they do this pub quiz thing usually
there's of course there's a winner but
there's always a loser there's always
some team that does incredibly poorly I
guess there is a wooden spoon generally
speaking yes in the tradition we are
going to give out a rubber mogul instead
the losing team will walk away this
giant inflatable raw joint ladies and
gentlemen so people will see you in the
street and give you their respect
are you ready Andy yes I'm ready were to
announce the winners okay we can only
have one man how many winters are so we
have two people that will face off in
the quadric on there it is the name of
the two winning teams our team Gretz
team grats ladies and we'll need a
representative from Team Bret's
with three correct answers nicely done
sir and those guys with a pointy arrow
representative Rose here we go Hey all
right first up man I don't even know how
I have to ask I know your name give it
up for Mike Burnie ladies and gentlemen
and your name I don't know what your
name give it up for Jeremy ladies
gentlemen all right
here we go okay
they both tied up so now we got to roll
the dice gentlemen each pick a die one
at a time two dice and - what do we got
first we got a three and a nine and a
nine or six no tonight is the time it
doesn't matter it's a both are higher
than three so Marquand give it up for my
grand right leg and Mike gave away his
prize leave it up to Jerry everyone
sweet a lot of generous people tonight
that was a lot of generous people okay
that's the end of the raw round takeover
I got to take a drink talk don't we play
the raw round baby raw round so we have
this next round is the education round
as I mentioned and to start off our pub
quiz every single question front in this
round comes from an education podcast
that we have performed so if you've been
listening and I know that Kevin has not
you will be able to get the answer to
all of these questions alright folks
we're about to enter round four pipe
down over there pipe down round four is
about to begin
put your hands together for Round four
[Applause]
here we go question number one and round
four get your pens ready got your cards
ready anybody need a blank card everyone
good here we go what percentage of their
brains do humans use what percentage of
the human brains do humans use this was
on identification folks you should be
able to get it don't believe the average
motion picture trailer yes what
percentage of the brain do humans use
question number two ladies and gentlemen
question number one is just a number
write down a number draw the little
percentage sign what percentage of the
brains of their brains do humans use
question number two
take it away Andy question number two
folks pipe down here we go the classic
children's
ring around the Rosie ring around the
Rosie refers to a tragedy in human
history
what is that tragedy classic child song
ring around the Rosie pocket full of
posies ashes ashes we all fall down just
like that Grateful Dead song what
tragedy does ring around the Rosie refer
to ladies and gentlemen take that space
on your little card use as many words as
you need to to tell us what tragedy does
ring-around-the-rosy refer to so a
child's nursery rhyme yes something
horrible yes just like London Bridge is
falling down actually was a drinking
song because London Bridge was actually
falling down and it became a children
song later so there's a lot of funny
origins to kids there's a little kids
Nursery Rhymes and this is gonna get
hurt in the London Bridge following day
nobody was hurt did anybody get hurt in
the ring around the rosies incident yes
ooh
ring around the rosey was a big one it's
a tough one all right a lot of folks
last time for question number two round
four what tragedy does
ring-around-the-rosie refer to and we're
heading into question number three
question number three folks here we go
settled down saddle downs so everyone
can hear the word piano is a nickname
for the musical instrument what is the
instruments full name piano just a
nickname it actually is a longer name
than that that's I did not know that yes
yeah not actually the name man that's
its nickname like how band aid is not
really the name its adhesive strip yes
harpsichord full name of the harpsichord
piano nickname for that musical
instrument what is that full name this
is the thing I'll probably remember the
most from today the new thing that I've
learned about pianos once I hear the
answer
well yeah the word piano is a nickname
for the musical instrument ladies
gentlemen for the final time in this
round
what is the pianos real full name the
pianos secret identity
alright number four here we go ladies
and gentlemen question number four round
four four four here we go Andy on
average how many cells in the human body
die every minute and this is a
multiple-choice question multiple tours
you just get to pick from three it's
gonna be it's gonna be easy listen up
folks quiet quiet quiet how many cells
in the human body die every single
minute on average you know different
sized people but on average how many
cells and the human body die a 3,000 B
300,000 or C 300 million cells dying
every minute a B or C ladies gentlemen
on average how many cells in the human
body die every minute obi-wan was a cell
he would every minute go I feel like
there's been a disturbance he probably
doesn't have cell Z as midi-chlorians
because that's true I'm gonna follow the
force on average how many cells in the
human body die every minute a 3000 B
300,000 C 300 million there it is so
there's lots of orders of magnitude to
choose from three thousand three hundred
thousand or 300 million cells per minute
see this I won't remember as much as
I'll remember whatever the piano is
called okay I'm hoping that it's like
something completely different than what
I'm expecting okay there it is last time
you're getting the question on average
how many cells in the human body die
every minute a 3000 B 300,000 C 300
million a B or C folks and we're moving
on to the final question of round four
number five here we go take it away Andy
McKelvey you might remember this from
our funny words around the world that we
did on the podcast Sean Bean famous for
playing Ned Stark on Game of Thrones
Sean
being but and and Game of Thrones was a
lot of that was shot in Ireland but in
Gaelic yes Sean Bean spelled se a and B
Hean means something else what does Sean
Bean in Gaelic mean and it's not dead
from Game of Thrones it's something else
so Sean man ladies gentlemen Sean Bean
played Ned Stark on Game of Thrones but
Sean Bean means something else in Gaelic
what does it mean what does Sean Bean
mean right down the translation of the
word Sean Bean and Sean Bean the word is
one word and it's spelt SCA nbh EAN Sean
bein yes Sean Bean not to be confused
with Sean Buster came all the way from
[ __ ] Ohio
Sean bus took the trip all right we got
cards up guys last time with the
question question number five ladies and
gentlemen last time Sean being played
Ned Stark on Game of Thrones but Sean
Bean one word means something else in
Gaelic what does it mean when you write
that down throw your hand in the air Big
Daddy Jimmy B and naked dolls will come
by and pick up your car throw them up in
the air ladies gentlemen they can strip
them from you and we can find out the
answers yes now if you had your
education book you could leaf through it
and find the answer to every single one
of these question with that form of
cheating be acceptable since you would
because they have brought bought the
book they can do whatever they want if
they buy that book some man all animals
are created equal but some animals are
more equal than others actually right
mr. animal fire me that's positively
Orwellian throw your hands up if you've
got a card ladies and gentlemen Accardi
cards outstanding ladies and gentlemen
all cards ready all in nobody else got a
card card over here card over you're
Nate on this side right here date right
at the bar close are you good
those who are tardy do not get fruit cup
all cards in closing this round five
seconds all cards in five four three two
one the rounds over we did it
about for everybody round four is that
an N and Andy is about to tell us what
the real answers were a professor and
rubric Alfred not a real professor what
percentage of their brains do humans use
humans use 100% of their bodies it's a
comment that people don't parts of your
brain will sleep during the day and
parts sleep at night but your brain is
every part of your brain is used to keep
you alive and do all the things you do
how come everyone thinks is less than a
hundred because it's a popular myth from
the 1950s where it was in some movie and
people are just like that's unbelievable
why that sounds like a science-fiction
concept so we could make something to
use 100% of their brain they be a super
person [ __ ] fake news all right here
we go
second second question ladies and
gentlemen what tragedy Andy would does
bring around the Rosie refer to folks we
got to keep it down over there please
all right what gravity does
ring-around-the-rosy refer to it refers
to the bubonic plague bubonic plague
plague we will take plague as an answer
why explain the story the story is that
there people were dying at the bubonic
plague that you had to keep the body in
your house and so the common practice
was to keep him from stinking everything
up was to stuff the pockets with flowers
that's where the line pocket full of
posy comes from and ashes ashes we all
fall down we all fall down means a lot
of people died and ashes ashes is if you
had more than three people in your
household died they would burn your
house down what yeah that's so they
bought a metal children's rhyme about it
tremendous isn't that nice there it is
if you had bubonic plague or we would
take plague will take plague folks keep
it down over there going through the
answers here we go
say again in England they say a tissue a
tissue instead of ashes ashes why a
tissue a tissue we all fall down is that
it because back then they were like
sneezing a lot more and everything as a
result of the issues and everything oh
my god he took a smart fact and made it
smarter give it up for him ladies and
gentlemen yes well done did he win this
round
okay number three the word piano is a
nickname for the musical instrument what
is its full name piano forts or
pianoforte and it means soft and loud or
soft and tough and hard so it sounds
like a Christine Lahti movie on soft yet
strong on lifetime what a wild [ __ ]
pull that pianoforte ladies gentleman's
the answer to number three number four
Andy on average how many cells in the
human body
die every minute a B or C 3lz 300,000 or
300 million 300 million cells a minute
died in the human body and they all go
into your poop booth and was that
question number four that was question
number four question number four
question number five ladies and
gentlemen the answer to question number
five and the winner of this round is
gonna walk away with full set of signed
education books yeah we've got five
copies of Education signed by the author
of your time by the author Kevin Smith I
mean Andrew McHale fish and signed by a
guy who's on the cover Kevin Smith so
you got two signatures in that book your
team's gonna win around the books if you
get the [ __ ] winner of this round the
last question was Sean Bean played Ned
Stark on Game of Thrones but Sean Bean
means something else in Gaelic Andy what
does it mean it means old woman Sean
Bean means old woman did anybody get
that right job we have an old woman over
here and he's just waving at the
bartender all right so there it is
there's all the answers to that round
man Andy came up with some brain a brain
burning [ __ ] questions and you will
find the answers in the education book
that's right all the answers for the
education round ladies and gentlemen
taken from Andy's book edumacation
available on Amazon right now if you're
watching at home but a team is gonna win
a one lucky team is gonna win five
signed copies of this they've only got
one person on their team
oh then they only get one that's fair
enough meanwhile we got time while
waiting for tabulations we
got time for a mini round who wants to
win a sign Kevin Smith ha okay how do we
do this there's a lot of people that
want to do it and I can't just go like
you so how do we [ __ ] how do we do this
every tear what is it
you got a roll of 20 all right yeah that
sounds good all right all right well how
many people right here's the thing
well [ __ ] now how did we do it there's
that was a the first person to just do
we conquer them through the Quadro gan
and just have them roll see yeah but
that doesn't make sense it's like ah
[ __ ] I don't know how to do it I brought
a prize and I don't know how to [ __ ] it
all right maybe we just do it the same
way we've been doing it you get a
challenge question yeah they were yeah
wow I'm woefully unprepared do we could
do with Sean Bean name five movies that
Sean Bean was in yeah was he I don't
know you got any ideas
Kevin says so what would that be give
them a mic what the [ __ ] what is it like
Simon Says but with Kevin that sounds
too like you know Kevin says take your
pants off like it sounds too I mean if
it wants to get sexy we can totally do
it that's true that's true I will have
to think of a way to [ __ ] do that
we'll come back to that in a minute
because we just got tabulated you got
the car I got the card sir all right so
we just figured out exactly who is gonna
win this round is it one or two there's
two people so we're gonna have to do
another go can I just ask a question I'm
not mad but why doesn't that [ __ ]
keep happening because I'll work on it I
wasn't blaming I'm just like
mathematically you're the smart guy did
you just because every team that has won
around has done it with four correct
answers right and but there's only ever
been to four correct answers cards per
round so it's actually a pretty good
pretty good game so far has anybody
gotten all five answers not yet really
yes not a single round
nobody had all five answered oh [ __ ]
that's interesting all right here we go
man
the two winners are cults of nigma we
need a relative nygma come on up and the
second team is death blossom we need a
representative from death blossom in the
house all right
see an enigma what's your name man yeah
sure yeah shove everyone give it up for
him ladies a job and death blossom
awesome your name was again Eric its
back lazy bum okay man
pick up dye and roll first don't pick a
diet yet don't don't
one at a time go what does he got 14
yeah he's got nowhere to be
we're totally got a b24 team man here we
go sixteen people on your team for you
take four books that leaves one for my
man everyone's a winner beautiful okay
man that's the end of the education
round so that brings us to the final
round ladies and gentlemen and this is
the shirt off my background whoever wins
this round wins this [ __ ] shirt that
I'm wearing right now this is a game
Warren Jersey I've been wearing for
[ __ ] almost a year however long I've
had this crisp I'll sign the back of it
and stuff like that so that's what we're
going for this is the shirt off my
background and as such the questions are
all related to the word back so this
time around for this week it's themed to
Back to the Future every question will
be about back to the future I'll add it
back to the future fans okay anyone need
a blank card does anybody need a black
card
everybody ready to play all ready to go
the shirt off of Kevin Smith's back here
we go folks the shirt off my background
man here are the questions starting
number one round five question one
give me your complete silence that's
better
what happened what popular cartoon
currently in production
is loosely based on characters from Back
to the Future there you go around
what popular cartoon currently in
production is loosely based on
characters from Back to the Future we
didn't hear the answer over there so
keep it down to yourself yes keep your
answers to your holiday blurt it out of
a [ __ ] response didn't realize the
growing competition this is not an
exhibition it is a competition
what popular course somebody's playing
for the shirt off my [ __ ] back keep
your [ __ ] mouth shut
what popular cartoon currently in
production is loosely based on
characters from Back to the Future now
we're going on a question - ladies
gentlemen get ready get those pens ready
get ready to write in that blank space
y'all remember the Soto's soda shop
Lou's cafe what was the name of the soda
shop busboy
don't say it out loud yes write it down
what was the name of the soda shop
busboy in Lou's cafe ladies and
gentlemen
everyone's they had quite an interaction
with Marty McFly's right he and her
already spilled the beans about what
happens to him in the future he had some
lines with the main character last time
y'all remember the soda shop Lou's cafe
what was the name of the soda shop
busboy round five question three ladies
and gentlemen what song here we go
question three what song does Marty play
at the dance that saves his brother and
sister
what song don't mark it play at the
dance that saves his brother and sister
they're fading out on the photograph and
yet when he plays they come back think
about it hard ladies and gentlemen what
song does Marty McFly play at the
enchantment under the sea dance that
saves his brother and sister they live
to fight another day and be in a
Polaroid here we go question for
question for folks
how much power does the flux capacitor
need to allow the DeLorean to travel
through time oh man
even under that mask I could see him
roll his eyes that is right how much
power does the flux capacitor need to
allow the DeLorean to time travel anyone
who has seen this movie is familiar with
this number you don't have to [ __ ]
know science or facts but this is a
number that just lives in your [ __ ]
brain I guarantee you it's taken even if
you're like I don't remember think real
[ __ ] hard you'll come up with it I
promise you how much power does the flux
capacitor need so that the DeLorean
could travel back in time fill that out
and we got one more question to go
ladies and gentlemen one more question
in round five and what's going to happen
is the end of round five somebody's
gonna win this [ __ ] shirt off my back
then
then what will you do is figure out who
won the entire night and that person is
gonna win the very first Ejim a
challenge coin which will allow them to
come play this game anytime they want
total [ __ ] bragging rights and [ __ ]
you could get laid off an edge of a
challenge coin I'm sure and the losers
the very last team the people who did
not win are gonna walk away with this
gigantic muggle as we learned today
right here at the okay final question
the shirt off my back round here we go
what are the names of Doc and Clara's
kids they're children at the end of Back
to the Future theory he knows it what in
Back to the Future three doc and Clara
had some kids what are the names of
those kids all right that was a good
question dude that was a steep cuts
because not everyone goes long and hard
on on three right yeah at four that's
true
there it is folks if you have filled in
all your answers what I want to do is
throw your hands in the air wave that
card like you just don't care
Big Daddy Jimmy V and Nate are gonna
come around collect him who wants to
give it a card he crushed this round his
way said Nate we got a card we got a
card cards cards everywhere cards yes
kind of hit him in though we got to get
the game going so if you have a card no
no and you want to hand it in please
hold it up nah time is up ladies and
gentlemen let's keep it going
ready bub up all right last card in we
got more cards over here got a couple
more yards down the on way and here's
one on the bar and in your cards folks
and we'll get to the answers round five
is at an end
da da da da we're asking for your green
cards we're not asking for your green
cards cards in there's one over here
Nate right there flying open cards in
ladies and gentlemen all right cards in
and 5 or 3 to 1 at the end of the round
badges
around 5:00 ok as always Andy has a list
of [ __ ] question answers for our
questions we will go through them right
now
what popular cartoon currently in
production is loosely based on
characters from Back to the Future
somebody already shouted the answer out
but Andy for the record Rick and Morty
Rick and Morty
Rick and Morty based on doc and Marty
okay number two y'all remember the soda
shop Lou's cafe what was the name of the
soda shop busboy who later on went on to
become mayor Goldie Wilson later Debbie
Wilson holy Wilson a lot of happy faces
with Goldie Wilson here in the audience
number three hit a Mandy what song does
Marty play at the dance that saves his
brother and sister and the answer is
earth angel earth angel man not Johnny
be good if you thought it was Johnny be
good you weren't paying close attention
the answer is actually earth angel blue
wrote down Johnny be good anybody yeah
well well good for being honest okay
number four how much power does the flux
capacitor need to allow the DeLorean to
travel through time on the count of
three everyone together one two three
1.21 gigawatts 1.21 jigowatts ladies and
gentlemen yes you should know that and
remember it like your childhood phone
number 1.21 jigowatts and number five
the question was and this was the
[ __ ] tough one for me what are the
names of doc and Clara's children at the
end of Back to the Future 3 Andy Jules
and Verne Jules are mode after
we got a lot of jewels and birds in the
crowd nicely done that was a [ __ ]
tough one man I can't have you got that
right
or pulled that at all that's nuts all
right so we're still waiting for the
final cards to be tabulated did anybody
figure out how to do this you want to
play Simon who's got what who spent the
most money that's got a good point well
you would know that yeah I don't go for
money
I guess JC's and whoever spent the most
money tonight that's a good [ __ ]
that's good what do you got man or or
well no I guess that's fair whoever's
got the most money gets its way yeah he
would know this bar Susan where are you
Susan Susan you [ __ ] water badness
all right Susan with the Mechagodzilla
question to anyone or just to use Susan
I'll put it Manti mo NT y e mo NT e
Monty won himself a [ __ ] pop he's
gonna get popped in the mouth
- I heart you Kevin McHale first no
thank you give it up first you won the
pop plays Johnny done alright still
waiting for our cards we didn't get
cards tabulated yet
let's kill time with another [ __ ]
shirt hey man who watches the Goldbergs
I have directed some episodes and I made
this Goldberg's t-shirt for the episode
where you know they did Batman on the
back it says holy balls Batman I worked
on episode 417 and Kevin Smith merely
watched that's what and on the front is
Lou one of the writers on the show his
kid drew this picture of the entire
Goldberg's family walking up the side of
the building like Batman style it comes
in size extra large
you'll be either buying for virgin [ __ ]
knockers or answering your question
correctly who wants to play right there
I saw way you're leaning against the
wall [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright this guy go right over there JC
what's what's your name Captain Mike out
here come over here so they can see a
stand in that slot what's your name my
name is Danny everyone give it up for
Danny man
get a question going Danny you're gonna
answer one question or you're gonna have
to buy four virgin [ __ ] knockers do you
agree to this I agree this font shirt
could be yours and the question Andy's
gonna ask is the Goldbergs takes place
in the environs of Philadelphia
pronounced how a Philadelphian would
pronounce it the word water h2o very
famous pronunciation and you have to
pronounce the word just exactly the way
they do and fill it up with say it in
Philly ladies gentlemen need complete
silence so we could hear this the man's
on the line for some money or t-shirt
say the word water like a Philadelphian
would know Oh Mike is off no offense
then from Philadelphia so what uh let's
give him three chances okay try another
first chance all right
hold on ladies gentlemen silence this
requires all this concentration the name
of the name in Philadelphia go ahead try
it again yeah wanna mmm getting closer
but that's nice that gives you one more
chance to not have to buy four virgin
[ __ ] [ __ ] knockers and walk away with
this shirt here we go quiet ladies and
gentlemen take it away what uh that's
not a head times that's not it man all
right that means yes anyone from Philly
when I pronounced it for us we got
somebody right behind you you want to
tell em how it's done
water that's it right there water Hato
on me and teary well deliverance is you
did get a Goldberg shirt at the bad news
you gotta buy some crappy drinks
together get our family a job well done
okay we got our cards we got our cards
ladies I got the results of the last
round the cards have come in and Andy's
got him and he's gonna tell us how many
winners were there there are three teams
each getting five correct answers three
teams five correct answers apiece fun
team number one
wait so all three of these teams got
every answer right that's
that's what five answers right means and
fair to say then then this was the
easiest round for everybody to play like
since everybody got the answers right
that's a lot of lis that's not but I
thought the jewels and burn question was
pretty damn hard I thought that was
stuff - I thought that would throw
people off but I get apparently a lot of
people saw three yes okay tell us the
names of the three teams and e.t number
one
smoochie Buchi team snooty Buchi send up
a representative right ear team member -
movie nerds team number three evidently
a a education superfan their team is
called Nora's oral flatulence oh yeah
Nora's oral flatulence setting up a
representative right now oh my gosh okay
man you guys are gonna enter the the
Quatro guy like 200 gone I keep wanting
to say quad dragon it's a dragon Quadra
gone everyone take a dice
we're gonna roll one at a time look at
the gentleman hands them out I know look
at that all right one at a time we'll
start with you and everyone wait until
the die and then I'll tell you right
right give it up for Ronnie's gonna do a
roll first
Ron it has a 13 and a 13 what's your
name my friend Andre it will give it a
broad drag
Andre you got to be 2:13 here we go
roll it 16 next day he took him out with
a roll
alright 16 is inevitabie Nats he
honora's oral flatulence represented by
Darrell give it up for Darrell
daughter's name is 13 yes it's a 13
there we go see Kevin Smith is taking
the very shirt from his back he is now
Kevin Smith is now signing so same shirt
signing it over to Andre yes
all right let's say he won the shirt off
my back
that Jersey is so big you could tent a
small family in that Jersey no it acts
as a shelter if you ever get caught in
the storm okay now we've done all of our
rounds yes so that means we know the
winner of that round we've given out all
the prizes now we just have to figure
out the results of this round first
they're gonna give us the name of the
loser round and so Nate is getting ready
to sprint that card over to us right now
so we're gonna give the loser instead of
a wooden spoon they're gonna walk away
with this inflatable muggle did you
inflate that yourself I did it has my
breath in it and my DNA right on the tip
so if you leave this at a crime scene I
am [ __ ] but also it's got your air in
it from your lungs so it's probably got
some THC in it - that's right you could
get high off of this you can open this
up and suck it in man so we're just
waiting on the final words all right so
that Nate and Big Daddy just waiting
these they're almost there second way
for the big blowup joint and then that
old that'll be the loser round that's
the that's the winning loser yes but
then we'll also know who the grant
program Prize winner will be announcing
for the final and that grand prize
winner will win the edge of a challenge
coin tonight's challenge coin is made
out of wood by me but will we replace it
with the metal challenge coins as they
arrive and that coin will entitle you to
five free game cards any night you want
to play and we're doing the show here at
the scum and villainy Cantina in Los
Angeles and before you go folks just so
you don't walk out empty-handed
there's a pile of stickers here from me
and raw so we'll leave them here on the
bar feel free to take a sticker holy
[ __ ] if you don't want a sticker I won't
be offended at all and [ __ ] but so you
don't leave empty [ __ ] handed and
whatnot there's some stickers up there I
know we're not over yet but while we're
waiting for the results we'll just take
the pulse of the audience are you guys
having a good time so far
so far so good this being the inaugural
one I thought it went smooth there's
some [ __ ] we'll be able to [ __ ] put
together and make smoother but [ __ ] this
was fun I was going forward to this for
a while yeah I know Kevin's been very
excited there's been a lot of uh
open boxes in his office as he pours
through movie memorabilia and clothing
and and this let's see while we're
waiting ooh all right there's the edge
of my coins right here it lays a
gentleman I have three pins from x-men
The Last Stand now you know we've had
many x-men movies and this is perhaps
not everyone's favorite but I'll tell
you right now you'll go long and afar in
this world you'll never run into these
[ __ ] pins again so you're picking
through like a dumpster or yeah possibly
alien could have found them in my
garbage but no I saved them for this
moment so we got three pins man how do
we give him out throw your hands in the
air wave my gears okay right there give
him a microphone JC while we're killing
some time
buh buh buh yeah what's your name young
camper Luke everyone give it up for Luke
[Music]
Luke you were in the right [ __ ] place
for that name this is a pin that
features Kelsey Grammer as Beast yes yes
they probably made 5,000 of these when
this movie was out maybe 10,000 but you
can't find this anywhere in the world
this is I'm not gonna say it's one of a
kind but [ __ ] this is rare and this
could be yours
if you answer the following question
yeah yeah okay let's do a grammar
question something from possibly a
podcast a friend of mine does called
talk salad it scrambled egg okay what
would a good question from that podcast
be named the guy who played Kelsey's
brother on Frasier
there are three names in his name he's
one of those cats like a Lee Harvey
Oswald but he didn't shoot anybody Mark
David chosen come on up jump up there if
you get good we hit that wall so but uh
there's a camera that points at that
wall
I think it's david Hyde Pierce you win
this [ __ ] man take that and with that
pin she could pierce David's hide
I was literally gonna guess Bob Billy
Bob but you're gonna have another chance
to win another pin this is a pin that
features vodka Jensen Jensen as yeah as
the Dark Phoenix and she's in this pose
like ah so this is like come on how
[ __ ] rare is that right now so this
could be yours let me see since this
farm could just all right how do you say
her name farm because I'm good Franco or
fama Lucas bunker like fan in a movie
that fomka was in with Matt Damon nobody
saying wait ah dang it I'm thinking
about taking with Liam Neeson can I just
neither of them while she was in that
movie Matt Damon met Matt Damon he seems
to know what do you want to give him
you're coming all right we got all the
lifelines tonight I'm sorry go ahead
rounders rounders is correct you win
this [ __ ] pin man well done my last
chance man this time around you got a
chance to win Halle Berry as storm
that's right
pin that was promoting x-men The Last
Stand that I've had in my office ever
since this movie came out and [ __ ] like
that so it's probably smells like we
answer a question let's see what's a
good alright
name the movie that I'm thinking about
that features Halle Berry and samuel
l.jackson Halle Berry and Samuel Elgin
Halle Berry difficult question
Samuel Jackson also yarn will get
excited and if you see someone else who
can win it for you you could pick them
somebody over there Mike swordfish Oh
Samuel Jackson was not in swordfish
either I don't think he was you were no
help whatsoever can I try again can I
look for the back over there I don't
work for this picked somebody else Oh
jungle fever yes right Andre is the king
of tritium give him that pin god damn it
all right when we have our results all
right so we killed enough time and now
we have our results do we know who's
winning the giant muggle we have ladies
and gentlemen quiet down here we go here
we go there's the end of the show
quiet quiet quiet now the part of
winning the wooden spoon award is
finding just how desperately terribly
you did and in this case perfect
stranger wins the wooden spoon with only
two correct answers for the entire night
perfect you dumbass this is yours
different operas going can you say
something about being so incredibly
wrong about all your answers you cannot
right eat dick for most serious errs
they're wrong yes that's true
don't rice eat dick for most of the
answers give it up for earlier you know
I I think we all learned something from
that we
do we now also have our winner winner
chicken dinner we have two teams tied
for first place
now what that happens yes is that there
couldn't be only one it's like
Highlander not like a Toyota Highlander
but the real Highlander so wait so to
get the edge of my challenge coin do
they they have to go back into the
quadriga or we make them answer a
question I feel like that's probably the
better like to roll a die for the coin
like if they're the trivia master they
should answer one question so you start
thinking okay we should just narrow it
down for me and I'll try to let's do
let's see well based on where we are
let's do questions about the movie JFK
all right well if you will just move
back into the left sorry I will get a
limb you want to hand me the education
book and we'll pick a fact out of the
book and make a question smart the way
to [ __ ] figure it out will be to ask
a question from the education book man
education book if you don't have your
own copy I think they're selling them
here at the end of the day also if
you're at home you can pick it up on
amazon.com first let's figure out what
are the names of the t's the teams that
are going to compete for the edge of a
challenge coin
Andy Mikkel fish the names of the teams
are Harry Styles buying bacon Harry
Styles buy bacon as a Yoko's reference I
appreciate it tourism sent over one
representative from your team and then
the second team team solo team solos
[Applause]
what's the mask oh my god he won the
pickle he'll look at that man turn
around to show that camera not only is
the education shirt but there's the
pickle on that Andy did a contest online
is that what it was it was here at the
continuing education that's it what's
your name captain Brian everyone give it
up for Brian one more time solo incident
Matt everyone give it up for Matt he's
been up here a couple times tonight
Brian and Matt are gonna face off for
the very first ever awarded edge of a
coin minted by Andy Mikkel Frisch
himself and wrapped in plastic like it
was Laura Palmer
this is made of coin they tell you I'm
made of nickel I would they tell you not
to take any wooden nickels and [ __ ] but
this one you're gonna want to take and
in about four weeks we get our real
coins the metal ones so you'll be able
to turn this in for the real coin or if
you want to be like [ __ ] I won't hold
onto the wooden one you could do that
too
but if it gets you eaten by a woodchuck
you lose so maybe the metal coin this is
the coin in question we'll put these in
there and [ __ ] now how do we do this
because they have to buzz in for the
answer is it first hand on the table and
they have to answer correctly I think
it's question for questions so you get a
question he gets it right he still gets
a chance to answer so he gets a question
he gets it right or wrong and he's so
bad his on so it could go on for hours
okay that's what I'm hoping
okay have you found one I have one here
we go boys so which way do we want to
start let's pick a die roll of dieters
they're gonna bullet dice roll a die to
see who gets asked question first fine
512 higher number go ahead here we go
here in Sam Raimi's film dark man Liam
Neeson has a real medical condition that
some people would consider a superpower
can you name his medical condition no I
cannot my god
that was [ __ ] admittedly a very hard
question but it's a tree and he says it
and it's in can I give you even a clue
to both of them it's also the lisbeth
salander's brother in Girl with the
Dragon Tattoo has the same medical
condition as she does and it's an
inability to feel pain can you name the
condition no no idea
the show is dying last an unanswerable
[ __ ] question it's called analgesia
and we've talked about another podcast
many times so I was maybe we should
maybe we should go with something fun
and stuff okay
let's see what movie should we do geez
I'm looking around I can't think of a
[ __ ] movie let's see something having
to do with no no no Kevin Smith
questions ah let's do a Star Wars
related question I don't know why I
think that but let's do Star Wars okay
Star Wars coming up with a question off
the top of my head
name or we're starting here named the
reptilian bounty hunter introduced in
the scene with Boba Fett busk
excellent job give it up her ladies and
gentlemen named the first Imperial
officer that Vader kills in Empire
Strikes Back
not even not an attempt did you say it's
not even the same it's an unfair level
of question it's a hard thing to do when
you're there enough we'll keep it in
bounty you know what [ __ ] you guys yeah
well just for the win or he gets to try
it so if he gets it right that he gets
anyways the game well first we're gonna
do whatever the question cuz they said
it is the same level as difficulty but
if you just want to show off an answer
it go ahead
is it Nita I don't know Wow is that
Rozzell Admiral Ozzel name is named in
the movie and busks name isn't so you
actually could get özil name because he
says clumsy as his stupid so that's
actually an easier question I think
because it's not expanded universe right
JC getting my back way is a joke okay so
bounty hunter question answered so it
should be another bounty hunter question
the name of the robotic bounty hunter
introduced in with Boba Fett ig-88
absolutely all right so that's [ __ ]
done god damn it next when you come up
with hopefully we're thinking of five
while I was trying to say I'm working
inside the fast I can't dive back in
Star Wars question let's see Star Wars
one do something for the Star Wars Clone
Wars universe no okay let's keep it that
everyone could play not if one goes back
to JC's got one Jason will come around
here's a Mike and face the camera you
know it's your bar - uh-uh okay what do
we move e trivia what is obviously we
were unprepared sensuality bear with us
as we
I know good Lord what is the name of
darth vader's Star Destroyer superstar
destroy the executioner oh [ __ ] I'm not
playing he had a question we've been
standing ok what type of rebel ship hold
on hold on quiet everybody here we go
what type of rebel ship crashes into the
executor in Return of the Jedi that
causes it to crash I'll say x-wing no do
you know who is in a wing he was a well
he's in a wing it's an a wing what does
the name of the mineral of the crystal
that goes into a lightsaber what is the
name of the mineral that goes inside a
lightsaber gives it its power as we've
learned in the more recent movies what
is the name of it Oh Kyber crystals
and you good friend or the winner of the
very first Ejim a-- challenge coin there
you are sir congratulations
thank you thank you for playing but with
that shirt in that pickle helm we should
give him a chance to win the measurement
coin right here we went to it right now
one question throw down okay and you're
gonna make me ask the question now again
right probably came up with that Kyber
crystal question that was really [ __ ]
good okay because you won the game but
then lost in the [ __ ] that thing that
should have been it but like we're soft
so there's a chance to walk away the
winner you are with another edge of a
challenge coin question is make any yoga
those are question no nobody saw yoga
hoes I know but then everyone else is
like we can't play cuz we didn't see
that [ __ ] and then they leave going home
go I'm like he's always talking about
[ __ ] yoga losers and they don't come
back and okay okay keep it broad no I'm
just showing you my logic I'll take
suggestions from the audience with the
brazen raise a hand if you've got a
question that you think is good one ass
behind right there yes bring a mic over
to him Andrew here we go who played the
devil and Dogma
there was no devil in Dogma I'm with him
if you're talking about the demon Azazel
as real as real sorry and that would be
Jason Lee right but that's not
he wasn't the devil no he was just a
fallen angel a demon devil take stuff
from him because he came up with that
yes you lose money for take the shirt
off visitor
you got one make me work for it well do
you want I do another Kevin Smith
question no not at all
okay I didn't want to do one in the
first place I'm looking for broad for
everyone to play okay fair enough I'll
take that what actor played boss called
Grissom in 1989's Tim Burton's Batman
won't rubber wolf is that guy what a
great guest that was the guy who played
the Ruby other NOx the great Jack
Palance I [ __ ] tried dude you did who
did give it up for a man whose [ __ ]
clothes pop tell you what so that you
don't go home empty [ __ ] handed you
get to walk away with a prize this is a
Justice League shirt that is about 4xl I
don't fit into it anymore
you win this give it up for my eyes
gentlemen and [ __ ] does that everything
did we cover everything that we have we
have a great prize grand prize winner we
have the loser we have everybody's done
we have finished the game well that was
the very first edge of a pop quiz did
you like it ladies John
next time we'll have all our bases
covered in [ __ ] and questions ready to
go we'll go a lot [ __ ] spy we'll have
a lot more question how to blast yeah we
basically we packed just enough and next
time we'll over pack and have lots to
[ __ ] go don't forget on your way out
man you got stickers here up on the bar
feel free to take them don't forget to
drive home very safely don't forget to
have a good time this weekend don't
forget to tell folks about the scum and
villainy Cantina located in Hollywood
Boulevard here in Hollywood California
give it up for the guy who wrote every
[ __ ] question made it possible
professor Andrew McHale brought a real
professor and that is education for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Andy McHale
friend you have been edgy Makeda can I
laser John